any good story usually has a good
backstory so let's start with you Scott
in 1971 you're at Princeton and you're
gonna write your senior thesis and you
choose max how did that happen well
actually we have to go back a little
farther when I was a sophomore I well I
have to go back before that I went off
let's keep going let's start let's start
when I was 15 when were you born
no we'll work we're in high school I had
to do the obligatory authors report and
at my mother's insistence I wrote about
her favorite author f scott Fitzgerald
and I became so consumed with scott
Fitzgerald that by the time I had
graduated from high school Palisades
high school here I had literally read
everything written by or about Scott
Fitzgerald I think in the English
language and the only school I seriously
considered going to was Princeton I went
off to Princeton I was on campus about
two days before I began going through
all his papers that were there and I
just kept seeing max Perkins popping up
everywhere and I thought who is this guy
I spent a whole day looking up every
reference I could find about Perkins
found almost nothing had been written
about him and then I decided gee this
could be a really interesting book and I
went to Hemingway's biographer who was
teaching at Princeton men named Carlos
Baker I mentioned this idea he said it's
a great idea for a book
the problem is whether you can do this
book since you're now all of 18 and a
half and and you're doing really solid
b-minus work here you might want to
think about well anyway he said why
don't you do your senior thesis on this
and if you're still interested then
carry it on and and write up write a
book so I graduated June 8th 1971 I
moved into the library June 9th and
began transposing what was my senior
thesis into a book and what a book it is
thank you very much
so John now well fast-forward a few
years this book comes across your bow
now I've read almost all the Scott's
books and they are dense and rich and
full of wonderful characters incredible
things that you would never know if he
didn't
tell us he paints these beautiful
canvases so was it dyed dog or eat the
hatchet how did you start how did you
when when it came to you what did you do
well I mean it it all started for me
with Scots book which I read in the 80s
and it just stayed with me and I thought
it was its a majestic biography and I
strongly recommend anyone who's remotely
interested in the subject of this movie
to read Scott's book it's it's
definitive it's beautifully written it's
just it's a masterful American biography
and to me it was a thrilling story of a
father and a son a relationship I just
found so compelling that it wouldn't let
go until I got a chance to to play with
it no Scott at any time did you turn to
John and say I hate to see the words go
I think at no time did I ever say I
don't recall John might remember am I
saying it better than I would but I
don't you know I remember actually
something that max Perkins used to tell
his authors who were having books turned
into screenplays especially Hemingway I
remember this came up a couple of times
and he said no matter what happens the
book doesn't change your book is still
the book it's going to be there it's not
now and in this instance I had a great
safety net in that John and I had known
each other for several years we were
very good friends by that time we
trusted each other and I knew what his
intentions were and basically I remember
the one thing I said that it relates to
your question is read the book one more
time John and then throw it out and then
write your screenplay that's what you do
you're the dramatist I've given you the
material fall back on it when and if you
need it right and Scott you know because
he grew up in a in a moviemaking
household Scott's father was a producer
he's written screenplays he understands
the work of a dramatist is not the work
of historian and I would I would the I
would be the first person to say what
you saw tonight was not fact it was not
he was not history it's a work of drama
and creating drama from fact which is
something I've been lucky enough to do a
lot in my career
sought it out requires a great deal of
torquing of history to make drama and
I've always felt that you could torque
history to a certain degree as long as
you didn't break it and you behaved with
good faith throughout you know I think
that's legitimate and Scott my very
close and the first five years of the 16
years of making this movie The Omen it
wasn't it's been 16 years of since since
I first seduced Scott into letting me
buy the rights you know after after just
a great deal of convincing you know
Scott and I spent about five years
working on the script and I would go
away I would write a draft
I would hesitantly hand it to Scott who
I adore but Scott is a scrupulous man
and we would have these dinners at the
old or so the sadly lucky you no longer
with us or so where we would talk
through page by page and sometimes line
by line exactly like max Perkins Thomas
Wolfe for five years until I felt I had
made a work of drama that I want to
stand behind and Scott I believe you
would say was involved in a work of balm
you felt fairly represented the
characters I've just jump in to say two
things the first is this isn't a
documentary this is a feature film and
that's what John intended to do and the
second thing I would say is I can't
think of an instance really where it
violates the book John has really stuck
very close to the facts of these lives
and certainly the spirit of the lives
that there's never a question about and
the only the only times I think there
are any slight deviations
I think only enhance the story to make
it work better up on the big screen I
want to talk about the sequence in the
film where max edits Tom's writing on
falling in love that sequence to me is
so amazing it's it's what the film is
about I mean it starts off very quiet in
Max's office and max reads all the words
to Tom and then it ends on the railway
platform with Tom reading just the right
words to the father figure
it's foreshadowing he gets on the train
and he goes away but he leaves him
enlightened and he leaves
more educated and that the idea of
showing the audience what it's like to
write to edit to collaborate to create
to fight all of that was all brilliant
and I just I just wanted to know if did
you feel like you needed this sort of
centerpiece did you did you try to show
people what it's like to write and edit
yeah that was it that was the last thing
that came into the screenplay knowing
that I needed that piece and Scott and I
talked a lot about there was something
so inherently uncynical too you know we
always pursued and we talked about it
our passion for writing because people
say to me well that's kind of a boring
job I'm like that's my job
- pencils going through words to be
thrilling I find when you change a
semicolon to a colon my heart stopped so
to me it was always exciting you know
every part of it yeah but I felt we had
to show that to the audience we had to
share our enthusiasm for pounding keys
and scratching words out and make it a
dance between these two characters make
it erotic and make it exciting make it
thrilling
so I resisted writing that for almost 14
years and then I finally said art it's
time to write this this centerpiece
sequence I'm glad I did I would like to
know what you think about let's see it
was max only outlived Tom by about nine
years so do you think that as mrs.
Bernstein prophesized there was a great
hush in his life after Tom passed oh
there's no question there was a great
hush in his life I mean it was a
terrible terrible blow for for Perkins
and then and a sad thing that happened
and it was very rough on Perkins is that
before Wolfe left oh as he left Perkins
and then took that trip around the
country where he sees Scott Fitzgerald
in Hollywood he had signed a contract
with another publishing house with
Harper's so they had a contract on all
the words that remained back in New York
Perkins was about the only one who could
read the handwriting on a lot of it on
and was the only one who knew where all
the pieces fit so these new crates came
into Perkins's office who had to sit and
these final two books the web in the
rock and you can't go home again and
then he had to hand them over to the man
at Harper's at to Edward as well so that
was just a real body blow to which he
did just for for Wolf's sake then what
happens the hush gets deeper bigger
wider and wider in that two years after
wolf dies f scott Fitzgerald dies at 44
years of age a few years after that Ring
Lardner dies
Hemingway doesn't die but his career
really nosedives
and I remember one day while I was
researching the book I made a list of
all Perkins's or as 50 major authors and
24 of them all younger than he pre
deceased him so what is that like for
this man to adopt all the mostly men
these young sons to see all his boys die
before him it was a killer and he became
in fact rather alcoholic in the end
himself oh yeah well I think we should
give max the last word and say well done
to both of you thank you so much thank
you